HAPPY MONDAY --
WE ARE PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
I'VE APPOINTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RICHARD BLOOM TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY.
ASSEMBLY ROBIN TAX COMMITTEE FOR
TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO. TO IT.
RETIRING BURKE HERE BRO. TO
BLOOM MAN'S.
MELENDEZ MULLIN [inaudible]
VETERANS NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE.
REAVIS.
KING.
WE KNOW YOU TO WHICH COUNTRY.
RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SECOND WHERE ANY EMOTION.
AND LOCALS AND A SECOND FOR THE
RULES.
ARE MOVE THE RULES.
ARE SECOND WHATEVER AND MOTION
AND A SECOND FOR THE RULES FOR
ALL MAKE THE MOTION THANK YOU.
QUIRK MAKES A MOTION THREE OF US
SECONDS --
THIS HIGHLY KALRA.
BURKE.
AYE BURKE AYE BRO.
BRO I TO BLOOM THIS IS ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE RULES.
LIVE ONLINE MAYES.
MAYES ARI AND THE RULES OF
PASSED.
I THE RULES OF PASSED.
A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE TO OUR
FIRST HEARING OF FOR ASSEMBLY
ROMAN TAX I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES --
FILL ICE AS WE TOOK OFF.
HOME.
OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
TODAY WE ADOPTED THE RULES ARE
READY BUT I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
QUICK MOMENT TO EXPLAIN WHAT OUR
NEW RULES ARE OUR RULES AND OUR
POLICY --
THE RULES ARE PRETTY MUCH THE
SAME RATE THIS YEAR AS THEY HAVE
BEEN ON SPECIFICALLY THIS A
WHERE THEY RULES OF THIS THING
OUT THE RULES ARE THE SAME BUT
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE ADOPTING NEW
POLICIES HERE FOR IN ASSEMBLY
REVENUE TAX.
SPECIFICALLY THIS POLICY GOVERNS
TAX EXPENDITURE MEASURES LIKE
CREDITS DEDUCTIONS AND
EXCLUSIONS THAT REDUCE REVENUE.
ABSENT EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES ALL THESE MEASURES
WILL BE INITIALLY SET FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY.
A VOTE ON THESE MEASURES MAY OR
MAY NOT BE SET FOR A LATER TIME
OR DATE.
IN ADDITION TAXES VENDOR FOR
MEASURES WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR A VOTE AND LESS AND UNTIL
THEY CONTAIN AN APPROPRIATE
SUNSET DATE.
FULLY COMPLY WITH THE STATEMENT
OF PURPOSE PARALLEL.
IN REVENUE TAX CODE SECTION --
FORTY ONE WITH THAT WE CAN OUT
WITH THAT WE ALREADY VOTED ON
THE ON THE RULES AND NOW
EVERYONE IS AWARE OF THIS YEAR'S
POLICY FOR ASSEMBLY REVAN TAX.
WELL WITH THAT WILL TAKE UP THE
ONLY BILL ON FILE AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN AND I AM PASSING THE GAVEL
OFF TO MY BASED YEARS SINCE I'M
PRESENTING.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE FILE
TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY
SIX ONE FORTY SEVEN BY
CHAIRWOMAN BURKE.
LET HER GET TO THE MIKE AND SHE
CAN.
BEGIN WHEN SHE'S READY.
MOVE THE BILL.
BUT I THINK YOU.
AS CHAIR I'LL BE QUICK.
I THINK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING PERCENT
AB ONE FORTY SEVEN OF THE WAY
FAIR IMPLEMENTATION AND SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A COMPREHENSIVE AND
BALANCE THAT --
OF POST WAY FOR TAX COLLECTION
RULES THAT MAKES SENSE FOR THE
CONSUMER SMALL BUSINESS AND THE
STATE -- AB
ONE FORTY SEVEN DOES SO IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS.
FIRST AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
PROVIDES RELIEF TO SMALL
BUSINESS BY INCREASING ECONOMIC
NEXUS THRESHOLD FROM
1-001-000-2500 THOUSAND AND
ELIMINATES THE TWO HUNDRED OR
MORE SEPARATE ACT --
TRANSACTIONS TRUSTS THRESHOLD
ENTIRELY --
THIS PROVISION ALSO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FREE
ADMINISTRATION BY ELIMINATING
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH TRYING
TO REGISTER AND COLLECT FROM
TRULY SMALL OUT OF STATE
BUSINESSES.
WHERE IN CIRCUMSTANCES THE COST
OF COLLECTION MAY OUT WEIGH IN
ON THE REVENUE GENERATED?
SECOND AB ONE FORTY SEVEN THESE
OF TODAY'S ECONOMIST ECONOMY BY
REQUIRING ONLINE MARKETPLACES TO
COLLECT SALES TAX SALES AND USE
TAX ON BEHALF OF THEIR THIRD
PARTY RETAILERS.
FINALLY A. B. ONE FORTY SEVEN
PROMOTES CLARITY AND SIMPLICITY
BY REQUIRING RETAILERS TO
COLLECT AND REMIT LOCAL DISTRICT
TAXES ONCE THEY SELL.
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
CALIFORNIA.
LIMITING THE BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENT TO TRACK SALES IN
EACH DISTRICT I WOULD LIKE --
TO IF SENATOR MCGUIRE WOULD LIKE
TO GO AHEAD AND GIVE YOU THE
REST OF INFORMATION.
THANK YOU MUCH CHAD MISTER VICE
CHAIR MADAM CHAIR WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU CHAIR WOMAN
BURKE --
ALONG WITH TREASURE MA FROM
BEING SUCH AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS --
IT HAS BEEN A PLEASURE TO BE A
TO COLLABORATE ON THIRTY THREE
STATES HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
THE COURT'S DECISION IN EVERY
OTHER STATE WITH THE SALES TAX
IS EXPECTED TO FOLLOW SUIT HERE
THE UNITED STATES AMERICA.
IN AB ONE FORTY SEVEN DOES JUST
THAT FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE MEASURE WILL INCREASE STATE
LOCAL REVENUE BY OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY MEANING
THESE LOCAL REVENUES ARE
DEDICATED LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
IN PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL.
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
THE FLOOR MISTER VICE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO STATE TREASURER
MOP THOSE BEEN 1100% PARTNER IN
THIS EFFORT WE CAN BE MORE
GRATEFUL TREASURE MARK.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT IS MY
HONOR TO BE HERE TO WORK WITH MY
YOU LIST OF SPONSORS --
OF THIS BILL.
US SOME OF YOU KNOW I SERVED ON
THE STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
UP FOR THE PAST FOUR YEARS AND
THIS WAS. ONE ISSUE THAT WE
TACKLED WITH --
MISTER A NICK MADURO'S WAS ALSO
HERE OF THE CD TFA AND HOW HARD
IT WAS TO COLLECT FROM SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SELLING.
ON SOME OF THESE ONLINE.
RETAIL MARKET PLACES --
AS WE ARE MISSING AT LEAST FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE SALES TAXES.
OM AND THAT'S ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MARCH REPORT BY
CAPITAL FORM --
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN COULD BRING UP TO A
BILLION DOLLARS.
IN STATE AND LOCAL TAXES JUST BY
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD SO I
AM HERE TO ANSWER QUICK AND
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU MADAM TREASURE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
.
KATE BELLS --
COMPLEX ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHORS OF THE BILL AND SPONSOR
AS WELL --
WE BELIEVE ABLE FORTY SEVEN BY
INCLUDING BOTH NEXUS AND THE
MARKET PLACE PROVISIONS WILL
CREATE FULL PARITY A POINT OF
SALE AND YET DECADES LONG
ADVANTAGE THAT OUT OF STATE
SELLERS OF HOW TO FOR BRICK AND
MORTAR SO FOR THAT WE ARE DRIVE
UP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WEEK APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT THE THE AUTHORS AS
WELL SPONSORS HAVE DONE TO
CREATE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD AND
WE LOOK FORWRD TO THIS MEASURES
MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A TANKER GO BE
AWFULLY A CALIFORNIA CITIES ALSO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
CHAIRS SO ON THIS ISSUE AND AND
THE SPONSORS AS WELL AS THE
STAFF IN.
IN CREE WHAT WE THINK IS A
CERTAINLY A WORKABLE ON
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE WAY FOR
DECISION AN IMPROVEMENT UPON OF
THE CURRENT REGULATIONS THAT ARE
PENDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEIA SOBRE THORN
CAL CHAMBER AS YOU KNOW OUR
MEMBERSHIP IS LARGE AND DIVERSE
GROUP OF BUSINESS AS MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
HOWEVER WE UNDERSTAND THAT SOME
CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS REGARDING
THE DEFINITION OF MARKET PLACE.
AND LIABILITY CONCERNS BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THEY CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIR TO ADDRESS THOSE.
THAT SAID WE APPRECIATE AND UPON
THE OVERALL DIRECTION THE CHAIRS
PURSUING THIS BILL AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE EFFORTS AND WE
HOPE TO BE IN A SUPPORT POSITION
STEP.
THANKS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LAURA BENNETT
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVISERS IN
BEHALF OF AMAZON WENT THINK THE
CHAIRS THE STRUCTURE FOR BRING
THIS BEFORE IN ALL YOUR GOOD
WORK THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARTY
TO CASSIE AND I WANTED TO THANK --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE CENTER
REQUIRED OUR STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA.
WE LIKE THIS BILL BUT WE DON'T
THINK THAT IT GOES QUITE FAR
ENOUGH AND I WANT TO SPEAK TO
ONE ASPECT OF THAT BILL BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND.
I AM AN ATTORNEY A TAX ATTORNEY
AND A LITIGATOR MY PRACTICE
FOCUSES ON CALIFORNIA TAXES
PETE'S EXCLUSIVELY HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AND SO I KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SALES TAX I REPRESENTED THE
SITUATION NUMEROUS SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO SELL AN ONLINE
MARKETPLACES.
AND FRANKLY MY PHONE HAS BEEN
RINGING OFF THE HOOK IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS AS A CD TFA.
TRYING TO DO A GOOD JOB BUT THEY
HAVE LET'S JUST BE HONEST
THEY'VE BEEN THREATENING A LOT
OF THESE MOM AND POP OPERATORS
WITH TAXES INTEREST AND
PENALTIES.
GOING BACK EIGHT YEARS AS WELL
AS CRIMINAL PROSECUTION SOME
CASES.
AND THIS IS IN THE MARKET PLACE
ON HAITIAN WHERE YOU HAVE AS AN
EXAMPLE AMAZON FBA SELLERS.
IN THEIR THREE POINTS I WANT TO
MAKE LEGALLY AND AND ONE IS THAT.
WHILE THE PROBLEM IS ADDRESS ON
A PROSPECTIVE BASIS IT'S NOT A
IT'S NOT ADDRESS ON A GOING
BACKWARDS BASIS.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THE
LEGISLATION.
AB SOME CLARIFYING LANGUAGE I
THINK COULD BE APPROPRIATE HERE
BECAUSE UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
WHICH HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR
AT LEAST SEVENTY TO EIGHTY YEARS.
REGULATION FIFTEEN SIXTEEN I'D
BEEN ON THE BOOKS ALL THIS TIME
SAYS THAT AND I QUOTE A PERSON
WHO HAS POSSESSION OF PROPERTY
OWNED BY ANOTHER.
AND ALSO THE POWER TO CALL ITS
TITLE TO BE TRANSFERRED BY
ANOTHER.
THAT PERSON IS DEEMED TO BE THE
RETAILER RIGHT SO WE HAVE THIS
BEING TAKEN CARE OF ON A
PROSPECTIVE BASIS IT WOULD BE
USEFUL WE HAVE LANGUAGE. TO TAKE
CARE OF IT ON A GOING BACKWARDS
BASIS IN CONFORMITY WITH
EXISTING LAW WE ALSO HAVE A
STATUTE SIX THOUSAND AND SEVEN
WHICH ESSENTIALLY SAYS THE SAME
THING.
AND THEN THE THIRD AND FINAL
POINT I WANNA MAKE FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE IS WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE CONTRACTS BETWEEN
ONLINE MARKETPLACE FACILITATORS.
AND THE SMALL BUSINESSES AND
SOMETIMES THOSE CONTRACTS SAY --
THE SMALL BUSINESS AGREES TO BE
THE RETAILER FOR SALES TAX
PURPOSES WELL UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW YOU CANNOT CONTRACT AWAY.
YOUR DUTIES AS A RETAILER.
BY VIRTUE OF SIGNING A PIECE OF
PAPER WITH SOMEBODY ELSE
OBVIOUSLY.
THAT WOULD OPEN THE DOOR TO A
LOT OF OTHER PROBLEMS WE CAN
JUST CREATE AN OFFSHORE COMPANY.
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH AFTER
COMPANIES MAKE THAT OFFSHORE
COMPANY THE RETAILER AND OBVIATE
AND RELIEVE THE ONLINE
MARKETPLACE WITH SO TATER.
FROM SALES TAXES.
JUST IN SUMMARY I KNOW THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT.
I TRIED NOT TO BE TOO TECHNICAL
BUT BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
WE HAVE LAW ON THE BOOKS.
IN FORMA REGULATION AND FORMER
STATUTE THAT.
SHOULD CONFORM WITH THIS
LEGISLATION THROUGH THE USE OF
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE SIR THANK
YOU THINK EVERY PATIENT
LISTENING.
APPRECIATED YOUR COMMENTS.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL RIVALS AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
NONPROFIT AMAZON SELLER
ORGANIZATION OR ICE THAT YOU
COMMERCE ORGANIZATION ALL THE
ONLINE MERCHANTS GUILD.
I WANT TO THANK.
BOTH SENATE AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FOR INTRUSIONS BILL IT'S IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT STEP FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS AND OF COURSE
I WANT TO THANK.
THE MOST A TREASURE Mà WHO HAS
BEEN.
WHO CAN SPEAK FOR THE REAL NESS
OF OUR MEMBERS AND THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE?
HUMAN BEINGS THE ARE NOT
MICROSOFT THEIR THESE AND I USED
TO WORK FOR IS A TAX LAWYER
THESE ARE.
SMALL KITCHEN TABLE ENTERPRISES
PEOPLE WHO.
MAY HAVE SOLD A MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT A MILLION DOLLAR SELLER
AFTER THEY PAY AMAZON THEIR CUT.
AFTER THE COST OF GOODS SOLD
MAYBE EATING OUT OF SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR LIVING WHICH IN
WESTERN KENTUCKY IS A GREAT LIVE
IT.
BUT NOW THEY'RE BEING TOLD BY
THE CD TFA THAT THEY OWE THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS TIMES. TEN TO THEM
FOR FAILING TO COLLECT THE TAX
FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS SIR IS
EIGHT YEARS SIX EIGHT YEARS.
THE TAX.
ITSELF HAS BEEN COMPLICATED THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WAS EVEN QUOTED
AS SAYING THEY THOUGHT AMAZON
SHOULD A COLLECTING SALES TAX
RESPECT TO THE SALES WHICH THEY
PERFIL.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT TYPES
OF MARKET PLACE.
AND SO EVEN AS WE SPEAK TO
AMAZON AND THE FOLKS THAT USE
THESE FOR FILM AND PROGRAMS AND
HAD NO IDEA.
THAT EMINEM WAS TAKEN THEIR
STUFF AND PUTTING IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE OTHER MARKET PLACES
OUT THERE THAT DON'T DO THAT AND
SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
KIND OF CAPTURE ALL OF THAT AND
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR THAT BUT
YOU KNOW WHEN WE SAY THINGS ARE
NOT BEING RETROACTIVE KEEP IN
MIND THAT.
THERE'S SORT OF A A GAME BEING
PLAYED AND YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE TRYING TO SAY THOSE THAT
USE THE AMAZON FULFILLMENT
CENTERS THOSE THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE GETTING THE THE THE
LETTERS CLAIMING THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE COMMITTING A FELONY THIS
IS RAY.
THAT'S THAT THEY ARE BEING
PERSECUTED AND AND FORTY
THOUSAND LETTERS WENT OUT TO
SELLERS VERY RECENTLY SAYING.
THAT DAY OWE BACK TAXES AND I'LL
JUST SAY ONE MORE THING ABOUT
THE AMAZON PLATFORM IT'S OFTEN
REFERRED TO BY FOLKS THE
COMMUNITIES THE GREAT EQUALIZER --
WOMEN ON BUSINESS ADVOCATES.
HAVE SAID THAT YOU KNOW THE
AMAZON IS GREAT WITH EQUALIZER
DO ITS ABILITY REMOVED GENDER
RACE NATIONAL OR NATIONAL ORIGIN
OTHER REAL WORLD BIASES FROM.
THE PICTURE AMAZONS MARKETPLACE
AND OTHERS GIVE ENTREPRENEURS
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR SUCCESS.
LEADING ON THE MARKET THE MARKET
BEING THE JUDGE OF WHAT SIXTIES
AND WHAT DOESN'T.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE ACTUALLY
HAD SOME OF OUR MEMBERS TELL YOU
THAT THEMSELVES SO YOU CAN SEE
FOR YOURSELF JUST THE TYPE OF
SUCCESS.
THE BEAMS ON SELLER OFFERS YOU
KNOW THAT HAVE BEEN FOUND ON
AMAZON BUT UNFORTUNATE JUST
SCARED.
THEY FEEL THAT THEY HAVE A
TARGET THAT BY BEING HERE.
THEY WOULD HAVE A TARGET ON THE
BACK BY THE CITY TFA AND EVEN
AMAZON WOULD RETALIATE AGAINST
THEIR BUSINESS. FOR BEING HERE
TO TELL YOU ABOUT THAT SO.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU AND FINALLY
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
THERE ARE FIVE MILLION SELLERS
IN THE NIGHT IN THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
SELLER ECONOMY AND NOBODY EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THEY EXPECTS
EXCEPT FOR TREASURE Và.
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES EXIST
IN THE STATE SMALL BOATERS ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES EXCUSE ME THAT
WASN'T.
AND SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE THEY EMPLOY PEOPLE.
OKAY THEY ARE AN ECONOMY AND NOT
ONE PERSON IN THIS ROOM OTHER
THAN TREASURE Mà HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED.
THAT THEY REALLY YOU KNOW REALLY
HAS GONE OUT AND SPOKEN TO THEM
ENGAGE THEM IN AS THE HARM THAT
THEY'RE FACING.
THE HARM THAT OUR SELLERS ARE
FACING OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE GETTING IT TOO FOR
MASSACHUSETTS WASHINGTON OTHER
STATES ARE LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA
WHO ALWAYS IS THE LEADER IN
THESE SITUATIONS AND SAYING WE
MADE IS THE SAME THING TO YOU.
TEAR SELLERS SO.
REALLY I HOPE YOU TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO WORK WITH ORGANIZATION
WORKERS TRUDGE MIND REALLY. FOR
THE FIRST TIME ACTUALLY GET TO
KNOW THE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ARE OPERATING IN THE STATE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND IF
YOU PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
PRECISE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LENNY GOLDBERG --
EMERITUS FOR THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION AND I WANTED
TO BE HERE BECAUSE WE STARTED
THIS PROCESS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WITH
INDEPENDENT BOOKSELLERS SEEING
AMAZON TAKING THEIR MARKET AND
NOT COLLECTING SALES TAX --
WE PARTICIPATED IN THE
STREAMLINED SALES TAX PROCESS
WHICH TURNED OUT TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT WITH REGARD TO THE WAY
FAIR DECISION BY THE COURT --
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS
ONE THAT IS WORKABLE IS
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW WE
DO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO KEEP
LOOKING AT IT AND SEEING IF IT'S
WORKING RIGHT AS OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE HAVE COMMENTED.
THE MARKET PLACE PROVISION IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE AND WE ALSO
AGREE THAT FIVE THAT WITH SOUTH
DAKOTA AT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
BIGGER THAN THEM.
SO THAT THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR --
THRESHOLD MAKES SENSE SO --
ALL THESE YEARS THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS COURT
IN JENSEN ON BEHALF OF TECH MAN
I'M MORE IN A SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE CAL CHAMBER AND
JUST REALLY THINK THE AUTHORS OF
THE BILL AND THEIR STAFF --
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK TO GO
INTO THIS AND TREASURER MOM A
LOT OF WORK TO GO INTO THIS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AS A MOVED ALMOST WORD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR COMMITTEE KEVIN
CAN WITH INTERNET ASSOCIATION
ALSO SO SHE MY COMMENTS WITH CAL
CHAMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KEITH DONE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE SELF --
COUNTIES COALITION THE LOCAL
AGENCIES THE SALES TAX CROWN
BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE WERE VERY
PUSH OF THE SUFFERED IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE GET IT RIGHT.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OFFICERS IN THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WE DO PROCEED IN THE BEST WAY
FOR THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
PETER WALKER THE CALVARY
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL --
POSITION WE ARE GENERALLY
SUPPORT OF LEGISLATION AND WANT
TO THANK THE YACHT BUT THE
AUTHORS AND STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND HOPEFULLY
WILL BE SUPPORTED IN THE FUTURE
THANKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
A CALIFORNIA I JUST WANTED TO
LET THE AUTHOR AND THAT
COMMITTEE KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION WITH
COMMITTED AMENDMENT TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
IT.
SEEN NOT A BRING ABOUT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISHING ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE OF THANK YOU SORRY
SEVENTY WITH THE CONSENT --
SO.
THIS -- YOU
YOU FALL THE MODEL THIS AFTER
THE WHAT HAPPENED IN SOUTH
DAKOTA YES IT'S A COURT CASE
RIGHT I WEAR THAT AGENT RIGHT IS
A COURT DECISION AND THE
DECISION.
MADE THE I MEAN CEREBRAL IRONMEN
SLIGHT GRADUALLY GESTURE THE
THRESHOLDS FROM WHAT IS NORTH
DAKOTA IS BASED ON THE FACT THAT
WERE IN CAL QUE SO THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IS.
IS GROSS SALES ARE TAXABLE SALES
GROWTH [inaudible]
TOTAL SALES.
OKAY SO YOU'RE NOT.
SURE YOU.
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET AT
WHETHER OR NOT ON TANGIBLE
PURPOSE.
SALES ON TANGIBLE PERSONAL
PROPERTY NO NO I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T MEAN THAT IN FRAZIER
CORRECTLY SO. FOR THAT IT THEIR
SALES FOR THAT FOR THE
MERCHANDISE SAYS THAT IT'S
ALREADY BEEN TAX FOR INSTANCE
AMAZON SOME.
SOME USE TAXES COLLECTED FOR
SOME SELLERS RIGHT OTHERS IT IS
NOT TO DO YOU SO DOES IT REMOVES.
SO I'LL THAT AMAZON --
ANSWERS THEY LIKE TO SO RIGHT
NOW AMAZON IS COLLECTING TAX ON
AMAZON SPECIFIC PRODUCTS --
SO THIS WOULD NOW OF A FOR THIS
USING THE AMAZON PLATFORM FOR
EXAMPLE THIS WOULD BE ALL NINE
AMAZON RELATED PRODUCTS SO THE
ACTUAL BRAND OF AMAZON IF
THEY'RE SELLING TO NOPE YOU'RE
NOT UNDERSTANDING MY QUESTION --
OKAY OR DIG USE TAX COLLECTED IS
THAT IS THAT REMOVED FROM THE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
THRESHOLD DO YOU SEPARATE THAT
OR IS IT JUST EVERYTHING IS PUT
TOGETHER.
SO THERE WERE NO TAXES ON THE
INTEREST ON THE INTERNET SALES
FOR PROP.
FOR IN THIRD PARTY RETAILERS WHO
DO NOT HAVE DID NOT HAVE A BRICK
AND MORTAR NO SALES TAX IS BEING
COLLECTED SO YOU GOT THAT PART.
SO NOW THE NEXT PART IS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT IF THE SALES USE
TAX IS TAKEN OUT.
IN ADVANCE TO THIS ONE AS ARE
YOU ASKING IF THE TAXES INCLUDED
IN THAT SO IF A PRODUCT'S TWENTY
FIVE BOXES TWENTY EIGHT WITH
TAXES AT THE TAX INCLUDED IN THE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND US I THINK
SHE'S ASKING NOT IF IT'S BEEN
TAX.
YOU REMOVE.
THE MEAN IS IT A PRE SALES TAX
TO ARE YOU ASKING A LOT
SHOULDN'T HAVE IT BACK YES.
BACK IN MY QUESTIONS.
IF I HAVE MADE IT WORSE. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ON THE PRE
AMOUNT BEFORE THE TAXES ARE
ALLOCATED ARE YOU ASKING IS THAT
WHAT THE QUESTION IS IS SHE'S
TRYING TO ASK.
NOW OKAY THAT'S WHAT YOU THOUGHT
WAS ASKING TOO RIGHT.
PRODUCTION.
OKAY.
I THOUGHT THAT'S MAYBE WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING BUT NOW OKAY
SOMEONE ELSE.
LANCE HER QUESTION WHEN I FIGURE
OUT WHAT IT IS.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING.
TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH I THOUGHT SHE WAS ASKING
WHAT YEAH YEAH SO WE ALL THINK
HE'S ASKING THE SAME THING OKAY
SEE NO OTHER MEMBER QUESTIONS.
BOUND JERRY CAN CLOSE THANK YOU
I'M A FEW THINGS ONE I WOULD
LIKE TO INFORM THE COMMITTEE
THAT BOTH THE CENTER AND I HAVE
AGREED TO REMOVE THE CLASS
ACTION PROVISION IN THIS BILL
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF TIMING THE
MEMBER WILL BE TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS.
I ALSO WANT --
TO COMMENT ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP FIRST OF
ALL WE ARE ALL A THINK
APPRECIATE OR SO OF SMALL
BUSINESS THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS BILL WE APPRECIATE THAT
SMALL BUSINESS IS ONE OF THE
NUMBER ONE EMPLOYERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO.
THAT IS THE ENTIRE DRIVER --
FOR THIS THAT HAVE GONE OUT TO
SELLERS WE ARE ALSO AWARE OF THE
RETROACTIVITY ISSUES AND THE
CONFORMITY ISSUES AND WE WILL
ADDRESS THOSE JUST NOT IN THIS
BILL BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH WE HAVE.
MADE THAT PROMISE TO A TREASURE
MA AND WE PLAN ON KEEPING THAT
PROMISE SO THEY WILL BE
ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL BUT IT
WILL BE ADDRESSED.
WITH THAT --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY MISTER
QUIRK A SECOND BY MISTER MAYES
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE I BURKE AYE
BRO.
BRO I CHU.
CHU AYE BLOOM.
MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN. ONE ON MY
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK OF FATE REAVIS.
REVERSE I TING.
TING AYE THAT BILL HAS.
BEEN.
THE BILL'S OUT TEN ZERO AND THAT
ADJOURNS REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE FOR TODAY.
ON A OKAY.
WELL OUT ON TO THE RULES YEAH.
OKAY.
SORRY IT'S MY FIRST HEARING THIS
TERM SO.
GET BACK INTO IT.
WE'RE GONNA ADD ON TO THE
COMMITTEE VOTES NOW.
THE CLERK CALLED THE VOTES ON
THE RULES.
HIGH.
MR KING.
KING I MR BLOOM.
WELL HOLD ON YOU NEED TO ADD ON
TO THE RULES AS WELL MISTER
BLOOM.
ON ON THE RULES DON'T HE WAS
HERE FOR THAT.
MR BLOOM AB [inaudible]
ONE FORTY SEVEN BLOOM ONLINE.
MR CHU ON THE RULES.
CHU.
CHU I'D [inaudible]
I'M NOT.
NOW THAT ADJOURNS A REVENUE TAX
COMMITTEE THANK YOU [inaudible]